Yeah, because there is there's, there's something there's,
there's something special about hotel Vegas. I'm just, I'm just like getting,
getting in like a hotel bed and just feeling like you're in a straight jacket.
I don't know, man. I love that. I don't like it when hotels do that,
when they you get in the bed and you're like, what is this?
The world's strongest, man for weight pulls up the like shimmy yourself into it.
I love that feeling. You feel like safe. You feel covered.
This is my safe zone right now. And no one can touch me. I feel like a moth.
I feel like a Caterpillar who was like about to,
what about it?
When they took like half the they under the front of them and it's like,
you're trying to tow a car when you're pulling the out.
You're like this on the bed. Like I just,
I just like shimmy myself in and I'm just like, ah,
I feel like I'm back in my mom's room by myself.
I can't even shoot me myself in. It's like,
I'm trying to get into pants five times, five sizes too small. It's like up.
I feel bad as well. When they put a lot of light,
they put like a cloth on the bed, like a little like, uh, I don't know,
like that's. They put on the front of the bed and I'm like,
get rid of that out of it.
Look the thing that like at the end linen thing or something,
I don't know what it is. You know what that's for? What does that for?
It's for apparently it's an American thing. Apparently it's so that you can.
With shoes on the bed. Yeah.
Oh, I'm about to leave right now. You probably seen it before,
like in hotels where it's just like this one, we'd like table cloths.
I hate that thing at the end of the bed. Right? That's the shoes.
That's the shoes.
But they do that in Japanese hotels where you have to take your shoes off at the
front. Yeah. That's what I'd done.
I had to stay in American hotels as, as the only white as the only white person.
No, no, no. Don't play this on me. I need, I need you correctly.
Shoes on sofas and beds. No, it does. Does that trigger you as it should?
Yes, of course. My parents would hit me if I did that. You kidding me?
I've never understood. I always thought, you know,
when you'd watch like the Simpsons or like American, like TV shows or whatever,
how they would take their shoes off before going to bed,
like they would like keep their shoes on the side of the bed.
And then when they wake up, the first thing they would do is put shoes on.
I just thought that was like parody. I didn't,
I didn't actually think Americans did that. I, I mean,
as much as America is most of the worst. And I'm like, as an Asian,
I'm just like, why did the West just normalize? Why y'all like dirty leg,
gross all shoes on the carpet. That's just gross.
That's what blows my mind. I'm like,
you are literally dragging like daily into your carpet. Yeah, bye.
And then, and then people complain being like, Oh man,
I hate carpet because it's so dirty. I'm like green shoes. Like whenever I,
whenever I would go to a friend's house and they would be like,
and I go to his house and he would be like, it's okay.
You can keep your shoes on. I'm like. Tell me to take my shoes off.
I want to take my shoes off. I would actually run. Like, I'm not a animal.
I'm not, I'm not going to bring dirt into the house. I don't know what it is.
But like when I'm.
With shoes on, in somebody's house.
You're so brilliant. I feel like I'm in a public restroom. Like I don't want to,
I don't want my shoes on. I want to be comfortable, man.
It drives me insane. Like, and there's people.
There'll be people coming to me. Like I wear my shoes in bed. Stop.
Stop, stop, stop, please. If, if,
if you want to go against the Geneva conventions, just do it, do it in your own
[inaudible] bed.
Of all our fans, except for the ones that wear shoes to that.
Oh my homie's in bed.
Oh my God. Yeah. Like, cause I went to, um, Jesus, my, uh, my editor, uh, Evan.
I went to his house and that was disgusting. He had like, he had like a,
a five inch thick carpet. Right. I don't even know what kinda,
I don't know what call this carpet was supposed to be,
but it definitely wasn't the color that came as this was viral. Dude,
Evan clean fix that carpet man.
And then they all wore like the dirtiest shoes inside. And I was like,
Evan icon.
Right? I'm like, have you not heard of house slippers?
Like if you have to wear something what's wrong with bare feet, man socks.
But even, even if it's like it's dude slippers, it's fine. It's clean.